citizens of the rejection we are back
with another DC Animated Universe film
not a DC AMU mind you because we are
watching part one of two of The Dark
Knight Returns now this is back to 2012.
we're not done with the present we're
not done with the future we're gonna
watch all of these but in the comments
I'd like you to let me know which one
you want us to watch next after part two
we're watching part two next that's
inevitable then we're diving back in so
let us know in the comments also
remember to like this video so we know
that you in fact liked this video hit
that notification Bell so you know when
more of these comes and remember to
share that Constantine video because
it's the first one that has done less
than the rest and frankly we liked it
it's intense it's a hard R you want
R-rated animated films you need to to
know they're popular and who knows maybe
DC is watching the reactions they're
like well you see this why we stopped
making our rude movies
it's not you it's on you somehow it's
your responsibility so share that one
particularly because I want to make more
the more of the constant demons because
we like those so let us know in the
comments hit that notification bell all
the YouTube things and
if you want to watch this in its
entirety from the beginning to the end
without edits in its full potent glory
and are watching faces
then head on over to the patreon because
the patrons get the full experience if
you'd like to watch us watch you watch
us that's the place to do it alright
without any further Ado whatsoever it is
The Dark Knight Returns part one
[Music]
I think cars are coming sounds like
racing cars it's not open with cars
I'm going Airfield oh planes okay okay
nope
ah you were right it's Gotta Have cars
the blimps always the blimps
[Music]
yes
live life a quarter mile at a time
everyone knows
he's redlining hit the nuts
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
so what happens when you try to push
past mach 10 Maverick come on
coffin for billionaire Bruce Wayne for
sure turns out Wayne bailed out at the
last second suffering only minor burns I
like his Bat racing helmet yeah just a
little yep
no I don't figure out this is Batman
death threats have once again been
leveled by the mutants again soon to
retire 70 year old Commissioner James
Gordon damn I've got one more month at
this job and I'd love to spend it
nailing the mutants if they want to take
me on come and get me I got one month
left of this almost too old
tonight also marks the 10th anniversary
of the last sighting of the
of that wherever he is he's enjoying a
toast with good friends great job at
adapting the animation style it looks
like Frank Miller her hair and like the
the bulkiness and the mutant
they're not like the usual Street Crooks
there's no Humanity in them at all
sounds like someone I used to deal with
things are different now Bruce the
government the public they wouldn't
stand for you anymore I don't know about
that Jim talk to Dick lately you know I
haven't shame you didn't keep up with
him after what happened with Jason oh
foreign
that's how I dance that's why I don't
dance
he's just dancing in the wrong City
that's true I gotta find a Gotham in
2049.
damn it Wolverine
no no
every time there's a sale on jewelry
brings him back don't go up Billy go
around behind him slice and dice show
him we're nasty
come on
oh no can't do it when they into it
can't do it when they're done revisiting
a traumatic memory he was just thinking
about pearls I can tell
oh floor oh
man I should have gone to therapy a
little EMDR might have helped oh
foreign
balls just remembering a promise Alfred
never again sorry I woke you when did
you shave oh wait it fell off
when did I shave I think he cares about
the weather I don't think this one's
cared about anything for a long time guy
doesn't even sweat look at him he makes
me sick great doctors man just such good
bedside manner don't be nervous Harvey
Dr willing and I have done outstanding
work on you I'm confident you're ready
to face the world and say hey I'm okay
and you look great too sure let's see it
oh I don't expect the people of Gotham
City to forgive my crimes overnight I
only ask that they give me a second
chance
see oh
kidnapping and murdering young children
a line even the limits hadn't crossed
until now despite the family paying the
ransom the mutants still took the boy's
life Wow many are already calling the
worst criminals Gotham City has seen
since the Joker
that's a direct challenge presentation
of Tyrone Power in the mark of Zorro
maybe just don't watch TV I don't know
it feels like it's not for you yeah it's
like the same three news channels in
this
and Trump why do I have the Zorro and
News Network it's a weird cable package
Bruce it's the bat package
got PTSD man
about to hit Gotham oh
you try to hold me back but you're weak
you're nothing but a hollow shell
that is an image
[Music]
man this is such a harrowing animated
film I never really captured Frank
Miller's dread and they're letting it
breathe which I appreciate yeah I like
that it's part one and part two so you
can honor it sometimes come
cool dang
oh
come in here where it's warm mommy yeah
please
no dark soft and make me feel safe
well yeah kill that guy Hawks off to
make me feel safe get pain in me Joanie
you're messing with my livelihood whoa
hey man take it somewhere else I just
had the seats cleaned shut your hairy
face and Drive Alabaster
a new master
Mess With Me
Nobody messes with the bear you dig
left the mink damn
I gotta get away with the cash
your blood money yeah you don't profit
off of being an I heard the
mutants hang here oh is that Sophia
lillis would play a good Stephanie Brown
oh sure
at least the lights are bright
just gotta find a way to make her hair
do that I mean the 80s is stranger
things tastic as is
[Music]
that's a gun my dude
where'd you go
oh
yeah
oh nice yeah
love when they do the strobing effect
with his movements and stuff always
Batman always
up there freaking weird
yeah
nice that was sick oh cool I didn't
think of that when I saw the lightning
that was perfect
iconic frame for a show kid I slowed
down there you are that's so cool
[Applause]
that was the Batman
oh the Condominiums soon to be built and
soon to be destroyed these men are mine
you heard the man you crazy I'm going in
rookie come on rookie like the seasoned
cop just enjoying the time he's been
waiting for this
this floor don't feel safe live
dangerously and shut up that's not what
people mean when they say live
dangerously my God that's living dumb
nice yeah he's a big old guy that's a
hell of a climb he's a thick Batman
floor safer now
freaky you never made noise before
oh steps
Batman's just out there
with fake horse hopes
oh now you've done it
you're under arrest Mister you just
crippled that man he's young he'll walk
again
but you'll stay scared won't you punk I
mean it get away from him he's being
patient with you as it is kid nice to
have your backpacks
yes
I was a rookie like schmuck face there
and tell Gordon we have to talk but
how's he supposed to get in touch with
you
you know how this goes now both sides
are two-faced but they both look like
Harvey Dent
um
we will kill the old man Gordon I myself
will kill the fool back fool don't call
us a gang we are the law Gotham City
belongs to the mutants
you seemed like a gang at criminals
pretty textbook Cyclops let himself go
really dark place
entire matter immediately my client is
the victim here Merkel draw Up release
papers for a victim here whoa whoa whoa
wait a second you're releasing him right
now
interesting
fun
I'm still the prime beneficiary in your
will aren't I
Alfred always Alfred such an inheritance
coming your way for the last year of
your life
Alfred lives forever he's like Keith
Richards that is true all that stress is
pickled them like the drugs are getting
pictures
another Batman so now you're going to
tell me what he's up to stay away from
me I got rights
ugh you're also bleeding to death and
right now I'm the only one in the world
who can get you to a hospital in time so
how quickly you decide to talk is up to
you sounds like Peter Weller it does I
wonder if it is outfit isn't there any
other way to contact him at least a
dozen then why so everyone knows
hidden
two helicopters stolen last night got to
be two-faced he's scratching both sides
now I wouldn't rule out that he's
hurting himself we're still talking
about dent
a Target that needs two helicopters
that's twice as big as anyone can
oh
the Gotham life building I'm absolutely
convinced
[Music]
games t-shirts neurotics like Harvey
drawing them into corresponding
intersecting patterns you could say
Batman oh no committing the crimes using
his so-called villains as narcissistic
proxies of course he wakes
foreign
[Music]
great too yeah this is Harvey Dent right
now I'm sitting Atop The Beautiful
Gotham life building right now I'm
posing as hush
two bombs big enough to make both Towers
Rubble you have 22 minutes to save them
and my price is 22 million dollars and
two tacos for Taco Tuesday
and two bags split evenly a two
two smoke bumps good Batman's on brand
theme he creates his village you know it
makes on him to play by their rules
cool
they're so good at making the poses work
oh the Frank Miller poses yeah
beautiful adaptation of the art
whoa sick there's some fear toxic
you're drugs kids not those drugs what's
happening your favorite nightmare should
last about an hour
two minutes of course I mean naturally
how do I stop it stop it it shouldn't be
going
oh he said we'd get the money and run
the bombs are just for show he wants to
die and take thousands with him can you
stop it
across your fingers
oh I don't know if you freeze a bomb
froze time itself
whoa damn
foreign
[Music]
s
or Rises you know what I mean
no show me
what did you do he's got four faces now
I played a long as long as I could just
look at me and have your laugh at least
both sides match now right they couldn't
fix me oh
nice commissioner ah wait forgot bean
sprouts well it sounds like she's got
you eaten right gotta watch the red meat
you know everyone's a doctor
look at prices
nice collection good good
at this boat
a lot of Alan more love can we just zoom
in on the comic rack please just live
there for a second
oh
oh poor guy I love that I don't remember
I know say
a mission to G Gordon has been shot and
killed
oh sorry I read that wrong
oh man
I'm 17 years old Macho cop
remember Chicago her parents are great
that was great use of silhouette yeah
cowabunga
Robin
good you got the the upper body strength
gymnastics training Galaxy broadcasting
President James Olson assured viewers
that the television writers strike now
in its fourth year what will not affect
this season's program oh God now it is
fourth year oh no and was that Jimmy
Olsen reporting two topical too topical
oh man
itself hold your breath once we get the
ransom we flush the whole kid jeez crank
is pissed
man
feel like it's a very Frank Miller
character it's great
ah Chill Spot it's just a bat
and it doesn't mean anything
whoa dude what is the turnover rate with
the mutants hi very high out of the way
spot
yeah
that was so cool back off or I'll kill
him believe me man I'll do it
[Applause]
and look at that the kid's calm is a
cucumber now combat weapons you're going
to tell me why you got them I'll tell
you but no cops you're in no position to
negotiate
wow
[Laughter]
nice surgical reveal
I slideways
look out I'm trying to make an honest
living here stay out of my business
what you know what those words mean
goodbye Keanu Reeves
you've been selling weapons to the
mutants my wife she's dying oh they
wouldn't pay for the treatment you sent
them enough Firepower to Stage a small
War if it's War they want I've got just
the thing I'm not talking speeches man
talking War the dump in one hour so get
in the dump
whoa
who else of course but the signal is
coming from in a while since I've taken
her out still purrs like it was
yesterday
hers like Earth a kid
bat tank
Gotham City belongs belong to the
mutants
are you sure about that
so trigger happy I don't even wait for
an order kids today no respect
Batman doesn't have his one rule in the
future nope he's he's too old for this
nice
I want to make a Batman the Stars Rodney
Dangerfield and call it the Batman who
could get no respect
cosigned
man
you really did give them enough for a
small army for a war nothing against the
bat tank like how did the Army not
notice all of this
[Music]
Awesome's a bad place
no oversight
rubber grenades
you know uh it's the thought that counts
all this metal and you don't even do
this look at that it's just a shell to
keep you safe
and face me like a man
sir you can't seriously
he's in his time he'll kill you it's the
only way I'll know wow
[Music]
hello
oh
you slow Spud
don't bring us back
oh
get in there kiddo
oh broke his visor
he already had to fix his Bat logo once
today come on you
[Applause]
that name
oh man
you don't need that now
oh plus that's for Robin
oh
yes
[Applause]
oh yeah
whoa cool
Clayface
I need a nap of Justice it's just a snap
[Music]
come on it's very strong that is a 300
pound man yeah that's gonna be the
heaviest body uphill in mud
girl thank you now run along home
[Laughter]
nope
now hold your breath
yeah
foreign
clever girl
the batsling
it's your name
Carrie
Carrie Kelly yeah sorry audience
Stephanie Brown and very different Rob
apologies apologies
failed the city one job koi
failed this city for 45 minutes people
have been yelling at me
it's cursing your credibility
it's been like a 15-year window since
I've read this
Stephanie brownson likes the current run
of the
I'm sorry no you need to defend this
yeah I do immediately
before these comments get I have she's
not even a robin
oh
the gallery
I think that she's standing just
adjacent to the other yeah
good call
[Music]
hands to yourself please
the password's just
I mean that's fair Alfred that that
should be hacking where'd he go
to find his strength
he's gonna watch Zorro again
this is a marathon on TV what he does so
the news watches Zorro
show us the butt man bat booty I feel
like Frank Miller would have shown us
the butt man that's true
I'm not finished yet
and you are not finished with me
oh
dang all the scars
me
oh
he is a monster striking at the
foundations of our democracy where are
the principles that make this the
noblest country in the world frankly I'm
surprised around a thousand more like
them damn those glasses thank you Scott
Summers
tonight we'll examine his impact on our
society from Metropolis managing editor
of the daily oh it was a lot of Lang
Gotham City popular psychologist and
author of the best seller hey I'm okay
Dr Bartholomew walper oh the Frank
Miller satire is great the misleading
short-term statistics but in the long
term a whole generation of young people
will be bent to The Matrix of Batman's
pathological self-delusion hey The
Matrix a man has risen to remind us that
the power
[Music]
this one man is showing us that we can
take a stand power to the people
with lots of money and resources yeah
the one percent
among those captured is one they're
calling the mutant leader I broke his
bones now my Mutant Army is coming to
storm Gotham City Batman got my nose
poop kill Gordon we will raise Gotham
and taste its blood prepare for war
prepare for trouble and make it double
Captain yindle stands firmly against the
Batman I intend to personally sit down
with the mutant leader to negotiate a
settlement what do you think Trish oh
this is a praise too
between this his strong stand on Batman
and his choosing a woman as the next
Police Commissioner I think we're seeing
a whole new mayor public perception wise
that is of course yeah good good
reminder
do enjoy the talking head interstitials
I love it it makes it feel so much more
like a movie yeah and it gives you so
much scope
how are you doing Mr Mayor
evening commissioner
of course it didn't take long
wow
wow bear is dead
mayor Stevenson had this to say if there
are any members of the mutant game
organization listening
is gels she's perfect with her help I
can end the mutant problem once and for
all have you forgotten what happened
with Jason
dang
it'll take weeks to prepare you properly
but I have a job for you tonight alter
my plan in any way straight from my
instructions at all
and you're fired and I will not give you
a reference for your next gig
Batman
so Frank Miller
the pipe
West River and 4
mandatory didn't hear it from me
Spud
I like that mix of like British slang
where they use rhyme scheme but also
like 80 slang yes with their mutant hood
that was I love the language you're a
good cop truth
truth mine since I was a kid
I don't understand
Batman
[Music]
let's not talk about Batman
of course we heard about the pipe of
course you did whatever
oh
I'm sure you've heard old fossils like
me talk about Pearl Harbor truth is we
were scared stiff we were hiding in our
beds with our heads under the sheets oh
and then we heard President Roosevelt on
the radio taking our fear and turning it
into a fighting spirit is why we won
that war
Batman's President Roosevelt yeah
I still don't see what that has to do
with Batman maybe one day you will
take the cycle back to the cave you're
done for tonight
how do you know it worked
and then voice Alfred for your hours
[Laughter]
thousands of them the only way to finish
this is to defeat them
humiliate them I'm counting on you
One Last Time You Gotta pants all of
them and film it come down to say hello
old man I Came to Say Goodbye
ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha
[Laughter]
foreign
the pipe
[Music]
know yourself I will show you who ruled
Gotham City
okay son show me son
dude
damn you're slow true but we're all slow
and we're thriving mud
ha ha
sure had mutants voice familiar too
come on bats
foreign
what was that just the right kind of Cut
Above the eyes
the kind it bleeds
leader Billy berserk Rob he Peg Batman
you see are we getting Pagan scene oh
Deadpool get it get it
oh boy oh no
[Applause]
oh
is that a tickle that was a nerve bundle
in your deltoid might not have hurt but
you won't be moving that arm for a while
nerve bundle
oh
you finished old man
hey this isn't a mud hole
it's an operating table damn
oh
now turn them over and spank him in
front of everybody
God damn
[Music]
the mutants what
we are the sons of Batman and Gotham's
criminals are about to enter politics it
works
oh it's so good just a bunch of
Vigilantes sons of Batman
oh
get your half eaten donut he's earned it
I know I should have been afraid but
this is my block the guy was mugging a
lady in front of my shop so I murdered
him with this the Batman has infected
the minds of Gotham's youth poisoned
these so-called sons of Batman with an
Insidious excuse for the most
so a bunch of psychopaths turn on
criminals instead of the rest of us and
you want to blame Batman I say more
power to them
sweet
[Music]
oh cool dude that was legit so Jay Lev
has been directing like most of them but
that was I think like one of the better
directed animated movies I've seen well
yeah I mean this seemed like and and
certainly I imagine uh dividing Peter
Weller great choice I feel like we've
heard it maybe one other time as Batman
maybe am and then Ariel Winter I know
that name was she Robin maybe maybe
David Selby was that big bad guy
or we're getting into the Weeds now yeah
I don't know these names but yeah like
dividing it up into two parts I imagine
really gives you like Frank Miller books
at least in my experience certainly seem
to have that air and that you know I
mean along with all those really strong
lights and shadows I just feel like
comes with a lot of atmosphere I love
that uses like a storyboard yeah like a
lot of times adaptations don't and I
feel like this directing was great
because they like loved the source
material well yeah it's like it has I
think I think you're right it's like it
has a nice blend of the Miller stylings
with some of that Batman animated series
quality worked in damn
that's why Bradley Baker
Michael Emerson's Joker that's cool
Michael Jackson was Alfred
Terror strong
all right Bruce Tim was uh Thomas Wayne
oh that's great oh I didn't catch who
the big bad was yeah we gotta go back
but I'm excited to hear uh Michael
Emerson as the Joker yeah it's gonna be
a lot of fun I like that legitimate I
love that Bruce Tim produced this and
also voice Thomas Wayne but like Bruce
Tim's such a legend in the bat space got
that new show coming yeah on Amazon now
no longer an HBO but on Amazon but yeah
like the way they might see a lot of
that oh sure people are Outsourcing
their shows for the bottom line and um
it's Max Max it's Max uh I think all the
original series that are uh that got
canceled are gonna get picked up
somewhere oh off of Max hopefully uh
fingers crossed but yeah like the way
they use the the artwork is storyboards
and the way they adapt a fair amount of
of the Frank Miller like dialogue style
to I mean it's like especially a parent
with characters like uh the mutants and
especially like hi my name is Rob like
like the the little quirks like yeah the
t-shirts and and the way they have their
own sort of like Noir Neo noir-esque
parlance that they talk in with each
other and the slang is like obviously
the delightful Frank millerism but even
the Batman speech like the this isn't a
mud hole it's uh
like that's all very Frank Miller he's
good at those and I and I do agree the
the framing but also the the poses and
iconography like there's certain images
of Frank Miller that sear in your mind
and they would like shape a fight around
them which was really cool and unique
totally like the fight would be made to
have that moment and like pause yeah it
was almost like a freeze frame loved
that yeah totally and and two like all
the Talking Heads with all the different
news reports and stuff like that and uh
you know just giving Gotham that extra
bit of life around the situation like
that's another thing that I sort of
associate with Frank Miller's style of
Storytelling and just even the Frank
Miller Batman stuff that I kind of
remember reading is yeah you have what's
the city chattering about what what is
the you know sort of and I mean people
debate Frank Miller's uh views and
subtext and whatever else but I like
that they yeah you utilized that and
gave Gotham and its response to all this
its own life I also love that Frank
Miller makes the world feel huge but
also Gotham feel like huge like like
you're saying with the Talking Heads
Gotham feels like a character which is
how it should feel like Gotham is a
character and not a lot of creators do
that to the scale and also on top of
that this adaptation allowed that to be
like a very integral part of how they'd
tell it yeah yeah absolutely and and
like the way to it uses I do appreciate
like reading some of these iconic like
not like you know uh compendiums and
graphic novels and stuff you know the I
think from the outside and and certainly
from like the live-action movie
perspective there's a certain quality
where you expect like okay well there's
like a main villain but I too appreciate
where that here you have like Two-Face
and the whole thing with him getting his
reconstructive surgery and what that
does to his mind and then you have the
mutants which is like the main thing but
you've also got the looming threat of
the Joker around the corner and you've
got you know somebody like a young
person becoming inspired and stepping
into the shoes of Robin and the fact
that it's like a young girl just feels
like kind of a kind of a miller-esque
subversion of of what you'd expect from
you know all the previous Robins prior
and because this is a part one and part
two we got to like see her family and we
got to understand her backstory but more
than we might have we got a little bit
more Alfred than we've had in a while we
got uh I really liked that Two-Face was
kind of like the opening villain but
also kind of the whole first act like
that really worked well and I haven't
read this in in much longer than I
realized because I don't remember much
of it which I'm really enjoying going
some remember the tone I remember the
major beats but a lot of it like I
didn't remember if that if Commissioner
Gordon died because Frank Miller is the
kind of guy that would kill him sure so
like yeah I mean like there's a month
out from our tire I mean he's 70 years
old that's when you killed like yeah so
I was like there's so many yeah little
suggestions like that too so it's fun to
subvert expectations even within the
Miller idea of things and and I'm really
glad I haven't read it in a while
because I I get to be surprised at the
turns it takes yeah this one's great uh
this is probably in the upper third for
me this part one yeah I mean I'm excited
to see the second half and just see how
they stick The Landing but I mean again
the amount of like breath that they've
put into this and and just care and
atmosphere I think is really is is
really wonderful I don't know it's very
striking and I'd say this is so like top
third for me but it's also I'm gonna
judge them eat separately but this is
definitely gonna go in that like uh when
we rank them a lot I'm sure this is
gonna land somewhere near the top
because this is so good yeah absolutely
where's our uh where's our guy yeah what
was a spiky nipple guy's name spiky nip
where are you at what's what's that guy
Dark Knight Returns uh mutants leaders
yeah that's what I kept saying oh he's
called me in leader okay is he just
called mutant leader I guess it's very
mad maxian yeah one and two and and
that's something I kind of associate
with Yuri's the Son of Batman
oh that makes me so happy oh that's
fantastic oh man have you heard his uh
Venom voice uh the the Symbiote
Spider-Man voice the Spider-Man 2
trailer I don't oh no I haven't seen
anything oh it's so cool the Spider-Man
2 trailer he uh yeah and he does look at
this awesome angry Peter Parker it's so
good oh sweet
I don't see him yeah I don't I I unless
they named him and I didn't catch it or
something like that I'm not sure I guess
it must be one of these one of these top
names here is he Hernando
he's like he's like mutant leader comma
Hernando
[Music]
um
Dark Knight Returns usually your voice
oh no that's that guy that looks like an
exclamation point
uh we had another voice is gonna drive
me crazy
Williams there you go oh that's awesome
I love Gary Anthony Williams yeah I was
trying to I was trying to place it
because his voice sounded so familiar
too and and it's like you know I really
like the uh yes it is him I thought it
was him okay yeah sure oh he is a
delight man he goes my coffee shop we've
become friends and I love that man very
much like he is he is a warm and
welcoming individual and we talk about
art all the time and he is such a nerd
like I love this dude I believe I I kept
every time he would speak and I mean I
liked his character voice but I was like
keep I keep thinking about Undercover
Brother
I don't know I don't know why I've just
got this feeling that's so cool then
yeah like you know I I do enjoy the
voice cast they've assembled for the
dcamu stuff but uh one of the most fun
things about you know going off the
beaten path and jumping out of
continuity is you know instances like
these because too like Peter Weller I
think is a terrific uh choice for Batman
yeah and and in a Frank Miller world you
know I feel like I mean you know if it
was Kevin Conroy it would be great sure
Jason O'Mara nice to feel super great
from from that to me yeah yeah and I
mean that's part of the fun is like you
know you gotta you gotta temper things
you can't have like a billion trillion
Batmans all the time but you know
hearing the different takes is still
part of the fun I've always seen Frank
Miller as not just the future but also
kind of an else world so I think if it
was Kevin Conroy I'd be a little
distracted because I'd be thinking of
the Animated Series Batman which I
consider a very specific Batman yeah and
I like that the I said it at the near
the top but the Gotham feels like that
art deco animated series mixed with
Frank Miller yeah this is 2012 so this
would have been like decently fresh off
the show
um so it's nice to have that world blend
so it feels more approachable and
adaptable yeah one two and two we were
in a kind of Miller's Sons by that time
right in terms of like the adaptations
online City would have been recent yeah
and 300 would have been around somewhere
in here too mid-2000s so yeah this would
have been within five years five ten
years of of the big Sin City uh 300 era
yeah yeah just like all the Striking
shadows and and images yeah it's like I
thought they did a nice job of animating
this in a way where you're like oh
definitely inspired by the Frank Miller
work but not like uh obnoxious so yeah
yeah yeah not that I guess it would be
but but yeah I thought they just brought
it to Life In A really lovely kind of
way and I love the tone and the mood and
Alfred must be 600 years old by now it's
all good yeah Michael Emerson is a lot
of people's fan casts for the Joker so
I'm really excited to his see his Joker
in the next one sure like to hear that
Vibe and like what that experience
that's gonna be great oh yeah and I love
the Slow Burn of like they really only
showed the hymn three times but you're
like you know what's coming like the
pacing's great well yeah and I love that
they yeah that they had the room to play
with something like that where yeah it's
like and two it's one of those things
where I think especially this first half
you're like oh yeah he's not even gonna
Factor necessarily but it's just about
that Awakening that that that little uh
spark of Life bubbling back up in the
yeah
happens in the forward round yeah
darling Oh I love also that like in a
theater I'd probably want these as a
full two and a half hour movie but sure
at home I love the hour 15. because it
lets it marinade you get to breathe in
it but also like I'm not at that point
of like okay I've been watching a movie
a while like there are some some I need
to be in the theater for long long long
content for whatever reason just to be
fully in it whereas this run time this
pacing everything's perfect yeah because
I was I I glanced at the at the recorder
time a couple of times because I was
like oh no is it gonna end I don't want
to end yeah you know and and I think
it's like these movies often fall in the
like hour 15 to hour 25 ish range and uh
and it's always special when you see one
where you're like yeah this felt like an
hour and a half hour and 45 movie but in
a good way like it felt longer than it
was in a good way this fully felt like a
feature film like this feels like a
complete and I love that it's half
because we got a 3X structure we got a
great Crescendo we got all and it's a
great adaptation of such a beloved book
like one of the more like I don't know
if it's gonna make the top five of all
of them but it's one of the more
impressive adaptations of anything I've
seen from comic to any other medium yeah
love this and we got all those comics on
the rest all the Alan Morris I think
they're all animal because it was they
look beautiful Vendetta it was Swamp
Thing it was Watchmen Sandman I think it
was literally an Alan morak yeah respect
which I was like I know Frank Miller is
written on some of these characters but
those were the ones of Alan Moore yeah
yeah yeah so big fan of the directors
are a huge fan of Alan Moore sure I mean
I'm sure he will never watch this before
no but it's always that's their way to
include him yeah like he won't see this
let's just put his covers up that's the
way to get back at him for something
they're like I know what he'll hate
he'll hate him
in Canon I like the idea that the the
gas station owner just really loves
alibor like he's just those are for him
he did the comics I'm stalking this is
all you get kids learn something yeah
let's get deep and philosophical and
there's a lot of like anti-fascism and
stuff in Alan Moore's work so I love the
idea that a fascist Gotham has like that
yeah that's the subversive stuff well
and I mean too uh Frank Miller certainly
gets dogged for his philosophical
underpinnings and uh he's not not a
violent man sure and some more fascist
leaning I think in his work and I think
it's interesting bullets you just blow
up a lot of guys yeah
which I mean you know is always going to
be I think present in a Batman
discussion and there are times here
where he's like ah you know this guy's
Not Gonna Die he'll walk it off or
whatever but yeah I appreciate too it
makes me curious to go back and read the
book and see if these are if those
particular because they do mention like
Batman being a fascist fascism
throughout this in little those you know
chatter bits in between and I wonder if
that's in the original text
we gotta address the Frank Miller in the
room yeah we gotta I love Frank Miller
but you know it's good uh it's
commentary sure sure yeah yeah it's like
I mean Frank Miller writes some
incredibly distinct and engrossing work
but you know it's all part of the
process I think the picking parts of the
philosophy Comic-Con the year uh we were
doing comic book shopping second season
other it was like literally right after
I got back from London to Jake
Gyllenhaal episode Jake Jalen episode
just aired so like Comic-Con timing was
every Creator being like Oh my God thank
you for getting this like because the
word got out about comics and like we
actually caused comic sales and I
remember I uh I was talking to Tom King
and I was so nervous I was more nervous
talking to Tom King Than Jake Gyllenhaal
like Tom King is a hero of mine to a
different way and uh Jake's one of my
favorite actors but I talk to more
actors for some reason someone that can
create stories I'm always like it's like
people that can make music I'm like your
brain's weird uh I just don't get it
like I don't I don't get how someone
hears them and goes like music anyway I
was talking to him and then he's like oh
if you met Frank
and he introduced me to Frank Miller and
him and Frank had just been talking and
I was like just let me let's
listen and then Scott Snyder came over
and I was like oh my God and then like
Josh Williamson and it was some of the
biggest writers at DC and like two of my
all-time favorite heroes in Tom King and
Frank Miller and I was like got to see
them talk about their Batman like they
were literally like when I came over
they were mid Batman conversation and I
didn't see Frank I didn't know like
Frank was there sure and it was just
like the most surreal conversation about
what Batman is to these people sure and
I just like didn't want to speak I was
just like let me listen I don't want to
be part of this I said listen it's a
private panel for you it was incredible
such an otter so yeah I got a picture of
Tom code Frank Miller and I was like
this is all I wanted uh it was like 20
minutes I could see her like a lot and
Frank's like 80 something and he still
has so much passion for Batman like to
see him like light up and have a lot to
say even though he's like you know he's
older and he looks frail when he's when
he's pontificating it's all power yes it
was really cool what isn't he bad is he
got a new thing out he's doing covers
right now but like this was four years
ago and it was it was like you know he's
still very old and frail but like
pontificating you you see a a 50 year
old man instead of 70 or 80 like it was
beautiful that's lovely I'm glad he's
out there kicking yeah I mean I'm so
jealous like that sounds yeah like nerd
Valhalla and he was great because he was
like smiling and talking and joyous and
as soon as I asked for a photo he said
yes it was really like happy to do it
but he did like yeah he did like a pose
he did like a he did his Rorschach it
was so good so I'm actually like way
happier that I haven't picked with Frank
Miller like grimacing at me and I was
like that's all right that's how I
remember him yeah yeah it was It was
kind of got an image tub yeah just like
and he did like a look down and I was
like this is so intense like Frank
Miller seems like the kind of guy who
would be a side like like a like a
character only appears once in a Frank
Miller graphic novel to like say
something kind of kind of snide but also
like it was not wrong yeah exactly so
yeah the Frank Miller uh Batman is is
beloved to me it's not always how I
perceive him but I love that this
returns world so much yeah absolutely
now this is this is Top Notch and I
cannot wait to see the second one yeah
love this uh for me it's like four and a
half Stars one of the higher ones for me
it definitely goes in the top third it's
gonna be fun to rank all these if you
want to see us rank them you gotta share
this you gotta leave comment you gotta
spread the words so these videos go
everywhere so we can keep making them uh
we were talking right before I think uh
we're gonna do like a separate one
Universe like the DC AMU and then I want
to do all of them and we're there's like
52 so far by the time we're done there's
probably gonna be like 55. but we want
to rank the whole lot so uh keep sharing
these keep loving on them keep
commenting so we can keep doing them
we'll be back very soon for part two uh
hopefully within the week we'll get to
part two so keep eyes peeled hit that
notification Bell thank you all the
patrons and uh yeah let's get into the
next one very soon share these love on
these thank you reject Nation you're
wonderful we'll see you very very soon
bye go read some comics
[Music]